If I genetically do not convert beta-carotene into vitamin A,
is there any sense in juicing carrots?
So nobody genetically does not convert beta-carotene into vitamin A.
If you have those G defects, the MCO or whatever they are,
then you have a more difficult time in that conversion.
So people that have a lot of defects in that gene family,
it would make sense for them to consume more vitamin A even as beta-carotene
because you need healthier dose of that in order to have an adequate amount of vitamin A reserves
for use in your body. So yes, to answer this question, if I have that genetic defect,
where I don't convert or have the possibility of not converting beta-carotene into vitamin A as well
if I didn't have that defect, is there a sense that you see carrots?
Absolutely, there is probably a greater need to do so.
Not that. You can't get beta-carotene and vitamin A from other sources, so I'm not saying that this
is a reason to do carrot. But if you want to do carrot juicing and you want to gain the nutrients
from the carrots and you have a beta-carotene, it's just one nutrient that you gain from
juicing carrots. So because you have that gene, it would not hinder you from making that decision to
introduce them, so I would say yes, go ahead with that.